he is uh the fifth overall selection of
the 1999 draft talk about more story
behind the headline
and he's got a new podcast out right now
called curious questions in which he
interviews his guests about their lives
and interests
using their astrological charts as his
guide
he is ricky williams how are you ricky
pretty good
pretty good thanks for asking it's been
a long time hasn't it since you and i
have spoken
i would think very long time yeah okay
um
so uh ricky um curious questions
um does that mean in this even though if
you're answering questions from somebody
else that have you pulled my
astrological chart for this conversation
ricky i have not uh okay i mean i would
have i would have loved you
i would have loved to have looked at it
because it's it's an interesting
conversation
and um you know a big part of starting
this podcast was
started way back in you know my rookie
year in the nfl and
and dealing with the media and i just
felt like the kinds of questions they
asked me
were were fine but they were only
speaking to me as a football player
and i've always you know been on a
journey to bring more of myself
out than just what i can do on the
football field and in that process
i became fascinated with astrology and
it really helped
me understand myself and understand my
life
and again it's been a huge passion of
mine and so now
as i i have a voice in podcast land you
know i get to
talk about what's interesting to me and
and ask the kinds of questions that uh
that peak my curiosity so then what what
would your ass for logic if i pulled
your astrological chart what would that
tell me about how i should question you
how does that sound ricky yeah yeah
that's that's wonderful so
um i'm a gemini okay and and a big part
of gemini really is
is is curiosity his curiosity has to be
has to be the the most important value
and so one question i'd ask myself is
is you know has my curiosity gotten me
into any
uh any trouble okay
and well has your curiosity gotten you
into any trouble
rookie it got me into a whole bunch of
trouble
yeah and you know to really expand on
this idea of curiosity
is being curious of what's beyond you
know what's beyond the known
and i think as a professional football
player everyone looked at me and said
you know you're living that you're
living a dream
like you should just stay here and keep
doing this as long as possible
and for a gemini that's you know that's
death
and so you know thank god finally i
listened to that voice and
in my head saying you know this is fine
and this is great but there's so many
other things in this world that you need
to explore
and you don't have that much time maybe
you should consider
doing something else for a little while
and that was my curiosity and it got the
best of me and i
and it enabled me to walk away from
from an amazing football career and and
travel the world and really realize
that i am a gemini that i get so much
more you know out of
traveling to random places than i do
scoring touchdowns on the football field
and that's what's real for me ricky
williams here on the rich eisen show i
have several curious
questions that i've been curious about
you uh for quite some time that i'm i'm
pleased to be able to ask you right now
if i may uh
first things first ricky if you were
drafted just straight up
uh and not had a team acquire
you by using their entire draft that
if you will set of circumstances do you
think you'd have had a different playing
career
oh no no doubt about that in in really
to me it's not so much about the
circumstances
you know i think had a different a
different team drafted me
and i went into a different situation
regardless
of how many draft picks there were i
think that would have been
been a big difference you know i think
truly uh when i when i came
out of the of the nfl you know the the
colts passed me up and and drafted edger
and james who
you know just made it into the into the
hall of fame and i think of just that
that situation you know if the
if the colts would have chose chosen me
and said edrin it would have you know i
would have started off
my career playing alongside one of the
greatest quarterbacks to ever play
in the nfl and peyton manning um but i
ended up in
new orleans playing alongside great guys
but
to billy joe's uh does anyone know who
these two billy this is the
this is my ricky williams trivia who
were the who were the two quarterbacks
well
ricky you've come to the right you
you've come to the wrong place to stump
it it's it's
it's hobert and toliver um so you know
but i i get what you're saying there's
no there's no mannings
in the mix yes yes and danny abramowicz
and
great guy right but dikka is a
old-school guy and he believed
that you know he rather have his friends
and guys that he trusts on his coaching
staff
more so than guys that actually can put
together uh to take advantage of the
kind of talent we had on offense
uh for the saints that yeah so while
we're i guess in a way
uh playing this particular if you will
game
what about the eagles uh donovan mcnabb
famously booed upon being drafted
uh because he was partially not you
a lot of the eagles were hoping that you
would be the eagles fans but you would
be what if you had gone to andy reid in
philadelphia
do you think that would oh my goodness
yeah because i mean
truly truly i'm i'm a west coast i'm a
west coast style
running back you know i know i'm a big
guy and i can run downhill but my
the best use of my talent is in is an
andy reid type system you know i catch
the ball out of the backfield i can
block i
i run hard and i think in that offense
and especially in a town like philly
where they love they love the
football i know that's one of the
reasons i went to texas because i know
if i'm in a
environment where they love their
football i'm gonna i'm gonna thrive in
that environment and so
and really that year i wanted to be the
number one overall pick i wanted to go
to cleveland
i mean i i just can see myself and you
know
being really a huge part of the dog
pound and just the way that i play
football and the way that i approach
things really i think
fit in all three of these systems that
you know that we just
we just referred to well you know and
ricky ricky williams here on the rich
eisen show
uh curious questions your new podcast i
mean you are as you know
pointed out a curious individual you're
a thought provoking individual
you're you're a thinker you're also
somebody
that um uh i would also say
doesn't share many similar traits to
mike ditko whatsoever
so did you guys meet before
you got acquired with all of the saints
draft choices i mean did you
did he meet you and they know who you
were before he's like let me hook myself
up
to this kid well i mean i i think you
know i think it all in all fairness
fairness to him uh i was you know i was
21 and so
to a certain extent right i was myself
but i was 21 i didn't know who i was and
especially at that point most of my life
had been dedicated to being the best
athlete i can which
you know and once i developed there then
i think the other part the more curious
parts of myself started to develop
but at that point i was i didn't know
who i was he didn't know who i was he
just saw that i could
you know run people over and score a lot
of touchdowns and i think from
his perspective i really i mean i think
it's been lost in my
in my narrative but i really am one of
the toughest
hardcore running backs i think to ever
play in the nfl i mean i was
in my haiti i was notorious that if
there is a defender and there is the
sideline i'm going for the defender
and i think did he love that and there
was one moment my
my my rookie year last game of the year
we're playing against the the carolina
panthers and uh
towards the end of kevin green's career
and we had a play where the fullback
missed his block
and i was able to like stop do like a
360 spin and make a diving
block to to save billy joe from getting
sacked
and i came to the sideline and dicker
grabbed me and he said you know i said i
love you said you're just hell of a
football player
and and to me that's one why i played
football in the first place
and two why you know although it didn't
go great in new orleans why i really
truly love playing for
for mike ditka ricky williams here on
the rich eisen show
uh so much again curious questions have
been bottled up for about 15
20 years uh that espn the magazine cover
uh do you have a copy of it somewhere on
your wall or or how do you view that
cover now
20 some odd years later ricky yeah you
know
so when um at the time uh one of my best
friends in the world dan levitard
um was writing an article for esp in the
magazine and he called me up and he said
you know we're trying to get we're
trying to get do something really
special with this cover
you know to show the connection between
you and ditka and so for a couple of
months we went back and forth on on
ideas and one day he called me he said i
think i got it he said how about you
know since you guys are like potentially
married to each other how about a
picture of you guys you know you in a
wedding dress and him in a
in a tux and i laughed you know my first
and i laughed and i and again
curiosity i laughed and i was like huh
that'd be interesting
so i said sure let's do it and you know
a couple about a month later we're in
new orleans we do the photo shoot and
we're in the limo
coach dick and i driving back to the to
the stage practice facility
and you know he has a cigar in his hand
he looks at me he's like
i don't know how they got you to put
that dress on but they if they if they
would have asked me i never would
i never would have done it and i looked
at him and i said why are you just
telling me this now
so the magazines the magazine comes out
and of course like the day training camp
starts and i get off the plane and
lacrosse wisconsin and all the media is
there with this
this matt this huge man you know how big
dfp in the magazine is huge magazine in
there and say what is this
and so it wasn't a great start wasn't a
great start to my training camp wasn't a
great start to my nfl career
but now i look back and i'm glad i did
it and times have changed and i think
people get the joke
more more so now than they do no doubt
about that i mean i i agree
and then um why master p how did you get
hooked up with him do you do you
do you think that that was a mistake for
you as well or you were just being
curious in that respect
ricky it's it's it's it comes from the
it comes from the same
place and again i think i would put that
in you know in the category of my
curiosity getting me into trouble
and this idea of seeing the way that
people do things until coming out of
college
you know all the slick the slick-haired
runners and agents who could come after
me it just felt so
dirty it just felt gross and
and this guy terry who was the runner
for for uh no limit sports
him and i really like we built a friend
like a real friendship you know what if
i was going through stuff aside from
agent and stuff i could call call him
and we could have real talk
and i just felt that just felt better to
me and so thinking about
what do i want my nfl career to look
like it wasn't me with the slick-haired
agent you know
fast regardless of how much money i
would have that just didn't feel good to
me
but having someone that i felt a
connection to who was by my side and we
were
building this this thing together that's
what felt good to me
and then so yeah go please go on and and
so i i started hanging around
you know no limit sports and just their
crew and it really was like a family
and fast forward we get to the contract
negotiations and my agent
a guy by the name of leland hardy who
worked for for no limit sports
he you know he sat me down he said okay
he said here here's how we want to
approach the negotiations with the
saints and he said this you know
he gave me three options he said this
deal this option would make you the
highest
the highest paid um rookie ever in the
nfl
based on you know guaranteed money you
know this one
um will you know it can make you the
highest paid
player but you have to earn it through
incentives and then he said okay and
this one is kind of in the middle
and these are our starting points and
immediately i said
my whole life i've hated watching people
on television complaining about how
athletes
make all this money you know and they
don't earn it and so i said i don't want
to be that guy and so i said i want to
take the
you know the max of the signing bonus i
get for being the fifth pick this year
but for the most part everything else i
want to have to i want to have to earn
and he looked at me and he said are you
sure and he spent
that whole weekend trying to convince me
to change my mind and i said you know
what this is something that
that that's really important to me
looking back
you know i think that i think that was
the thing i would change is
i was 21 i'd never missed i'd never
missed a game high school college so i
didn't
i didn't think that there was a chance
that i could hurt a very first preseason
game i get a high ankle sprain
missed 10 10 games my first two my first
two seasons and so
that that put me behind the eight ball
trying to trying to meet those the
antennas that i that i put into my
contract oh
my gosh ricky williams here on the rich
eisen show
so how do you look back at your career
ricky how do you
how do you view it now through these
things
well you know two to two different ways
you know one it was important for me to
to get to that ten thousand yard mark
you know i felt like
through all the ups and downs and
everything that i that i went through to
still walk away
um with 10 000 yards in technically 11
seasons but one of those seasons was
only a quarter because i
tore my pec so so almost averaging a
thousand yards a season
considering the last half of my career i
wasn't even the starting running back so
i feel like
i left my mark on the field but more
importantly you know when i was a kid
and i thought about
becoming a professional athlete it
wasn't for the money or the fame
it was to have a platform and the fact
that i'm now you know i have a podcast
where i get to talk about astrology
um i feel very good about i feel very
good about my career that it's put me in
this position
where's your heisman trophy where do you
keep it um i sold my heisman trophy and
so
uh i don't even know the guy who bought
it so it's at some guy i'm guessing it's
in some guy's
uh trophy room i didn't know that
um when did you do that why'd you do
that there's a big
there's a big story a couple of uh maybe
a year and a half ago
where i guess the heisman signed some
uh they they made the winner sign a
contract saying after me that
no no more heisman trophy winners could
sign their uh they could sell their
their trophies and so mine was the
actually the last that could be sold
and i actually sold it several years
back so
it's in the news but one of my um close
friends
became my financial advisor and about a
year after
about two years after i retired i got a
call from the irs
saying that i hadn't paid taxes in three
years and so i was like
uh what are you talking about so i
called my financial advisor
and and come to find out that you know
she pretty much had stolen all my money
and so kind of had this this come to
jesus moment where i woke up one day and
i was like okay
what am i what am i going to do with my
life and i realized that because of what
i've
accomplished i had enough resources to
to get myself
on my feet and start to to rebuild my
life and so
and so that's what i did wow
and so now this pod um who do you want
on it
what do you want to do out with it ricky
well
you know we started mainly heavy in
sports
uh a couple of icons in the cannabis
industry i i've talked to i got a chance
to talk to
my agent my eventual agent lee steinberg
um but but really i would love to talk
to interesting people from all walks of
life
because what i'm trying to what i'm
trying to to to show people
is that you know people have so many
ideas about what astrology is
and to me it's just it's a useful tool
to help you understand other people and
help you understand the world
and i think in in the format of these
conversations and asking questions and
giving people a little bit of
astrological insight based on what comes
out of the conversation
i think it introduces people into this
at least in my opinion one of the most
amazing
uh languages or symbol systems um out
there
and again it's a passion of mine i love
talking about it and so
it's i feel very fortunate for this
opportunity so tom brady's a leo
um he was drafted the year after you and
now he's just
uh won his seventh super bowl ricky uh
you're also uh
all about wellness and and maintaining
um
what do you what do you think of this
what is what is him being a leo tell you
about what tom brady can continue to do
do you think yeah so in so in general
you know uh
leo the the the lion has a lot to do
with the sense of royalty
right this idea of letting your light
shine
and so i think it's important for all of
us but specifically leos
to find that area in life where they
truly shine you know
and for me and i think all a lot of
athletic african-american a lot of
athletic kids
you know especially boys right we think
that our way to shine is by being a
professional athlete
and and for tom he's about he's found
his
he's found his way to shine for me it
wasn't football i feel like what i'm
doing now
this astrology work talking to people
this is this is how i
shot and what's interesting on
astrologically so on the super bowl
during the day of the super bowl the
planet jupiter okay the planet jupiter
was
was interacting with with tom brady's
leo's son
okay and so whenever we see these
interactions between planets
it's it's opportunities you know i think
if astrology is telling us what the
weather is like
and for for you know this month okay
said what month of february february if
i was talking to tom brady regardless of
who he was and what he was doing
i would say this month is a golden
opportunity for you to shine
for you to shine bigger and brighter
than you've ever shot
and the fact that he he has a habit
of doing this you know that that's an
easy bet easy easy bet
based on tom tom brady astrology
and what life was presenting in in uh
now for him during this month so uh yeah
because
that month is always the month the super
bowl is going to be in too
my goodness uh my my uh my signs
uh cancer what what does that mean and
uh as we end this conversation
ricky what can you tell me what i mean i
i i think
right right dead on with cancer is the
nature of this conversation
you know most of the time most of the
time when i talk to
the people in the sports media the the
conversations
are more superficial and the truth the
cancer cancer is about getting getting
to your heart
you know feeling comfortable talking
about the things that you mainly only
think about inside of yourself
and so a big part of cancer is family
right those and i don't mean blood
family necessarily
i mean those people where you feel like
you can really share what's on your
what's on your heart it's on your mind
because if we don't feel safe enough to
share what's on our heart we don't ever
get the opportunity to get really in
touch with ourselves
and so and so cancers typically tend to
be introverted because
they're more interested in in the inner
world and and i would guess that
a lot of your interest in in what you do
is really getting to the story or
getting to the person
that's you know underneath the helmet
underneath the uniform that's what i do
that's what i love to do and that's what
i love to bring to the audience and uh
anytime i'd love to return the favor if
you so choose to have me on your pod
ricky it's been way too long since we've
chatted i'd love to do it yeah that
would be off the fabric i'd love to
absolutely thank you for this chat you
take care of yourself ricky let's do it
again soon
you bet that's ricky williams ricky
williams rick the laureate on twitter
williams on instagram hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here